Warning: This video has been heavily censored
due to YouTube removing the original upload.
*cough* Pussies!
Please check the links to the uncensored version
in the description below for the full effect.
For the rest of you who are either sneaking at work or
watching this with your mom in the living room, here you go:
If any of you have been following anime for any decent period of time,
you'd know that a staple in the whole
medium itself and all its sexualized fighting,
harem-inducing, and cutesie-moe glory is the idea of fanservice.
Now, for any of you who are new to anime, might not
be so familiar with anime concepts and the otaku lingo,
allow me to fill you in.
"Fanservice" is a term derived from
the anime and manga fandom itself
to describe material that is intentionally added to a series or show
with the purpose of catering towards a certain group of people or fans
and giving them exactly what they want.
The definition of the term itself is actually quite vague,
since basically anything can technically be defined as fanservice -
which could range from anything to a shot of the character's panties,
making the art style emphasize cute, ditsy girls,
or even the inclusion of a little sister character because, in the end,
it all boils down to a concept of, well, servicing the fans.
Nowadays, though, "fanservice" is normally a
phrase used by anime fans - myself included -
to describe the gratuitous depiction of
female characters in a sexualized manner,
which normally equates to the unnecessary
exposure of female body parts
by means of dodgy camera angles, randomly-inserted
sexualized scenes, or revealing clothing
that is only worn for the purpose of emphasizing every possible asset.
Or, to put it in guy language:
fucking titties, fucking ass, and fucking girls, man.
It's a topic that surely anyone watching anime has probably noticed.
And as one of the many reviewers that have complained
about fanservice getting in the way of the quality of the show,
it does beg the question: What is the point of fanservice?
Well, the answer to that question is so simple and obvious
that I'm sure 90% of the people watching
the video would be able to answer it.
Sex sells!
I said it years ago in my Harem video and I'll say it again now.
It doesn't matter if it's in the film industry,
gaming, music, or even selling fucking burgers.
Sex makes money and that's just a universal
fact, especially if it's aimed towards guys.
Most of the time, we cannot help it.
We are subconsciously drawn to this stuff,
as I'm sure many of the people who
clicked on this video just for the thumbnail
are about to comment on,
and we can only blame our hormones for that.
So, having said all of this, of course it's obvious
why most anime have fanservice in them!
"So, what's the problem?" you may ask.
It's something I often like to complain about in
my own reviews, to which a common reply I get is,
"Pfft! Why is Gigguk complaining about tits again?
Does he not like girls or something?"
Well, of course I like girls, you dunce,
but do you know what else I like?
Being so immersed in the story that I forget about everything else
and become completely engrossed in the
world that the anime's presenting to me.
I watch anime to enjoy the story, the
action, or just as a form of escapism.
And it's kind of distracting if they're
trying to make horny at the same time.
Or, are you going to have me believe that
there are people who can stay totally engaged
in a serious story while simultaneously wanting to have a wank.
Shut up, Shinji!
There's only so much fanservice someone can take
before it acts against their immersion in the story.
The more obviously placed the fanservice,
the more likely it is to break immersion,
which is my biggest problem with fanservice,
unless that's the entire point of the show, a.k.a. the ecchi genre.
I have no problems with the ecchi genre as a whole,
since you go into the show expecting this stuff.
My big problem is that not only are we seeing
this more and more in modern-day anime,
but it's also getting progressively more extreme,
no matter what genre a show is in.
And the thing is that it's become so predominant in
anime in this day and age that we, as hardcore fans,
don't really notice it anymore.
Or, at least it seems like we've just
accepted things as the way they are.
To make my point, let's rewind back a decade ago
to have a little look at an anime called Love Hina.
Love Hina is a harem comedy that came out in the early 2000s
whose plot involved a university dropout finding
himself living with a bunch of beautiful girls.
It was a completely tasteless and average show,
even if it was one of my guilty pleasures.
But, my point is that most of the comedy derives from the
main character stumbling into a group of half-naked girls
or accidentally finding himself in sexual
situations for one reason or another.
So, you'd think that such an anime would be
riddled with every kind of fanservice there is.
And, for its time, it kind of was.
You had your usual panty shots and tit flashes in every episode,
but looking back in comparison to today's
standards, everything seems kind of tame.
Even looking at similar shows at its
time, such as Negima or Vandread,
you'd see that everything seems a lot more
toned down, more subtle, and less explosive.
Fast forward to the modern day and now we have
over glorified crotch-shots, daylight tentacle rape,
bullet-dodging breasts, and anti-bomb boobs.
In One Piece, you can visibly see how breast sizes
have gradually grown in the course of a decade.
And heck, in 2012 alone, we've introduced toothbrush sex,
spit fetishes, and hot zombies to the huge list of weird-ass shit
that we just look over because we've just accepted
it as a part of the craziness of anime.
But, looking back, you have to ask yourself:
When did all of this start to happen?
In my time of watching anime, it wasn't always like this.
And from what I can remember, it was
somewhere between the 2007-2008 period
when I started to notice the transition.
The mainstream release of the perverse
fight-gasm that was Ikki Tousen,
the glorified sexualization of Yoko from Gurren Lagann,
and the sudden amplification of Karen
ass shots from Code Geass R1 to R2.
Don't get me wrong; the idea of fanservice is not a new concept at all.
It has existed for as long as most people can remember.
Going back to the '80s, you had Fujiko from the Lupin III series,
who was the poster child of fanservice for that era.
But, never before has it been so predominant
and oh-so-obvious as it is now.
Has anime become so reliant on fanservice
that companies have no confidence
that a compelling story and interesting characters
is all you need to make an anime sell?
And, worst of all, have we, the fanbase, glorified this?
Debating over which Bleach character has the biggest breast size,
arguing over our waifus,
creating thousands of new memes out of the
latest incest fetish that spread like wildfire.
I'm looking at you, 4chan!
It just seems that fanservice has not
only become the normality in anime,
but it is progressively getting more and more extreme as time goes on,
as if animation companies are constantly trying to
one-up each other in a contest to shock the viewer.
And the otaku community has just evolved
to accept any kind of toned-up fanservice
for just the way things are right now.
So, where does it stop?
Is a line ever going to be drawn or are the handful of
shows without fanservice going to become even rarer?
I only say this because I love anime as a
medium of storytelling and entertainment.
I want to get more people into anime and spread the love.
But how can I defend the dignity of a medium
against the childish and pornographic preconceptions
the general populace seem to have of it
when it looks like the medium doesn't even have any dignity in itself?
While it can be argued that fanservice doesn't actually
add anything to the quality of a story or characters,
I would be lying if I said I wanted it to disappear completely.
There are still great shows that have fanservice in them and,
no matter what us guys say, we will always
be subconsciously drawn to the T&A.
And I know you girls secretly love your manservice as well.
All I can ask is that the creators try to just tone it down a little
and have a bit more dignity in their own series because,
as with everything else, it needs some moderation.
The way things are going, though, this current trend
of fanservice doesn't look like it's slowing down at all.
Perhaps one day, fans may get tired of it and demand something else,
or perhaps the die has already been cast past the point of no return,
so we should just all get used to it and move on.
So, I'm asking you guys now:
Do you think there's too much fanservice in anime nowadays?
Leave a comment of video response for
your chance to get featured in my next rant.
Anyway, that's it from me now, though, so if you want to know
where my promised Part 2 of the Big Three Rant has gone,
....just look in the description.
But, in response to my last rant, what
do you think of the Big 3 and its fans?
[TheLOROnline]
Whether it be the fans praising it as the anime
sacred enough to have descended from the heavens,
or the haters condemning it for, quote,
"RUINING THE ENTIRE ANIME COMMUNITY,"
there's always some sort of overreaction and argument going on.
Before I continue...